kelly vous craquerez vous attend oui on
l'a mais bon c'est vrai hp vient de
extrêmement fidèle n'arrêtait pas vous
arrêtez pas vous regarder on va voir les
garçons qui avaient dans l'île sur l'île
de la tentation vous êtes noir vous
craquerez ou pas mes filles parce que là
vous faites les malines mais quand vous
allez voir reggae sur lyria coup je
m'appelle j'y revienne on arrive un
groupe de boudin avec moi comme ça et on
peut les m'appelle ce bar de lille avait
pas eu la vie sauve à une bonne et on
arrive tous traités comme des jumelles
non trop problème etc et amateurs là
sur les sodas loti néral avec cette
étude mon frère raconte avec un mondial
ça soit en bonis de la tentation c'est
l'île de la cité en pédalo la vie vous
mettez pas de magnéto et intel sont
anciens surtout l'amour n'existerait pas
alors mesdemoiselles
préparez vous à découvrir lors de ce
séjour
l'existence d'une véritable
dans la vie de quelqu'un très optimiste
et très loyal et qui adore tout ce qui
allège maintenant par contre les
notations à tenir donc je peux vous
assurer que tous les jours ce sera votre
saint valentin
merci on m'appelle ghost mais pas comme
le fantôme ce ne sont pas les flics ne
serait pas transparent si parmi vous je
trouve celle qui me plaît je la mettrais
sur un piédestal
merci je vagabonde entre la france et le
costa rica août et je viens
principalement pour des papiers en
choeur on verra ce qui se passait
nouvelles paroles
[Applaudissements]
la meilleure phrase je dois gabou entre
la france et le costa moi dans mes
soeurs et alors là à aller nager du mal
les textes appris par coeur comme comme
d'aucuns moi je préfère tout autant dans
ton île de la tentation à toi son idée
lara sera soit réglé ils voulaient pas
qu'on te fatiguer m'ont fait vraiment
une frénésie à l'arrivée je vais faire
l'arrivée
[Rires]
et même 4 à 10 nous fera fut le guen se
régler la délicate baptisée la pub wade
il a les tétons les plus longues de loi
de l'histoire bon sens villa n'était
tout va bien quand il m'a pub avec des
camarades y aller on va continuer à
parler de vous mariages pour une lune de
miel
[Rires]
les sondages de l'île de la tentation
indien qui c'est quoi les questions la
pause est tellement de questions et même
pas à 78% sécurité morts ça y est c'est
ses chocolats